[Musique]
des plantes médicinales des fleurs
d'ornement un potager des espèces
oubliées désuète voire austère le jardin
du presbytère de chédigny reprend les
caractéristiques d'un jardin de curé du
19e siècle il n'y a plus de curé depuis
45 ans dans la commune le jardin lui est
revenu y avait des fonctions également
de soigner le curé et ses ouailles
jardin de l'apothicaire les plantes
médicinales officinale également de
pouvoir cueillir des fleurs pour l'hôtel
très très important aussi
donc il ya un jardin de godbout côtier
auteur du livre jardin de curé jardins
d'antan philippe féret et aurore claudie
mangue hold on crée scénographié le
jardin et si monsieur et l'érudit des
variétés végétales
madame s'est chargé de la symbolique
entre les douze apôtres le baptistère et
les autres références chrétiennes
pour cela le celui de long et on arrive
à la croix la croix dans la symbolique
la verticalité l'horizontalité est le
point central de la foi là et puis on
termine cette bonté parce que cette
année est en progression en verre vers
une bonté
pariez pas encore installé mais elle
c'est la source de vie pour la mise en
forme la paysagiste a dû trouver des
espèces très rares comme saisonnier de
peau est très sombre
c'est que la vie d'un curé du 19e siècle
ne laissait que peu de place à la gaîté
au total plus de 500 variétés tapis ce
jardin fraîchement conçu mais le but
c'était aussi de les trouver tout dans
l'eure dans leur variété en fait parce
qu'il y avait des petites subtilités des
plantes rares et c'est pas facile de les
trouver donc il a fallu aller chercher
la perle rare chez des producteurs un
peu spécialisés ou des producteurs un
petit peu atypique
ça n'a pas été facile en fait c'est pas
nos producteurs habituels
le projet a été lancé il ya deux ans a
coûté 150 mille euros entre le ministère
de l'environnement la région et le
département
l'association des roses de chédigny a
mis au pot 30000 euros et avec un droit
d'entrée à 3 euros
l'espoir aussi est cultivée de créer un
éclairage pour des visites à la tombée
de la nuit